give a billionaire a popular social
networking site and what you get well
another billionaire and his own
remarkably similar version of said
social networking site it's Elon Musk
versus Mark Zuckerberg Twitter versus
drumroll please threads aptly named for
a rival app and bearing a striking
resemblance to its main competitor you
can post text updates up to 500
characters long along with links and
photos and other users content appears
in your timeline I've got the Sky News
account up on Twitter and threads to
show you the likenesses so this is
Twitter this is threads look at the
layout and the way the text and video
appears
even the way that users can like comment
and retweet or repost is so very similar
you'll need to use your Instagram
account another Zuckerberg site to get
onto his new platform he had tried out
the name threads for a different app in
2019 it didn't look like this and it
didn't really take off but the brand has
been recycled it seems for disillusioned
tweeters like Emma Jane Palin an
interior stylist relying on social media
to promote her business I used to be on
Twitter and I used to love it and then I
think it went a little bit depressing
and just a bit kind of dark with threads
just because my audience from Instagram
is obviously coming over and it's nice
to speak to people in in more of a
conversational sense which actually I
never had with Twitter Elon Musk fired
80 of Twitter's staff after he took over
last year and he made unpopular changes
to the app like drastically limiting the
number of tweets users can see so does
threads spell the end for a site
hundreds of millions of people use
ultimately the history of Technology as
it shows that consumers will flop to the
the product that they like the most and
we've seen this year whether you take
from Myspace in the early days of
Technology right through to tick tock
and Instagram use this little shift with
what they think is the best product and
I think we'll probably see that in the
social media space right now as well
while being a big old copycat is not new
in the tech World Zuckerberg's latest
Venture is extremely well timed when it
comes to dissatisfaction with Twitter
whether Elon Musk Rises to the challenge
well he's not a man known for his
predictability Becky Cottrell Sky News